SPEAKER: Making friends here
is sometimes what saves
people's lives.
Or what gets them up out of bed
in the morning.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
I am a teacher
for Helping Hands,
a sign language community
here in VR chat.
Hand rested under elbow
and we're gonna go like this.
Christmas.
Slow, quick, quick, slow.
If I had confidence that I could
teach dance as a living in VR,
I totally would do exactly that.
SPEAKER 2: With a long distance
relationship,
having VR is a game changer.
SPEAKER 3:
We are 5,000 miles apart,
but we're gonna try our best
to make it work.
SPEAKER 4:
This year has been really hard.
The thing that has kept me sane
has been VR
and the VR community.
I would not have weathered this
without you guys.
Three, two, one,
happy New Year!
(DINOSAUR ROARS)
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
SPEAKER 5: You can be
who you've always wanted to be.
And you can,
in a way, start over.
We can come together
and support each other.
This community
means a lot to me
and I really want them to know
that they're loved.
-SPEAKER 6: True.
-It's been a year since...
-SPEAKER 6: That's true.
-...I've seen Kevin's IRL body.
(LAUGHTER)
-It sounds funny.
-"Kevin's IRL body."